ex-girlfriend has a bunch of green flags
john
john okay do you mean red flags or green
flags
yeah hey rich uh thanks for taking my
call uh she had a bunch of green flags
actually so good things yeah i recently
watched your video on the on all the
green flags
and as you were going through them you
know i was realizing basically before i
preface saying my ex-girlfriend is kind
of the reason why i'm here in the red
pill uh community
uh but i was thinking i was as i was
going through them i was like well she
had that she had that for example
she didn't do uh she didn't partake in a
lot of social media
um she wasn't a ball scorer she had she
had a great career
um
and she basically you know
she didn't
she just basically had a lot of the
green flags she had
and that's pretty much why i feel like
i'm still having this kind of one-itis
because i keep thinking about her
and i guess my question really is just
how do
i basically kind of move on from
somebody like that or told you that i'm
thirty-one
and girlfriend for you like did you guys
uh second we dated for about a year um
and actually the reason we broke up was
because she moved to another state
and you know i just i'm over here in
california and i just i didn't want to
leave california and i was basically the
crux of it
um and so i guess i'm having an issue
with
if i do find
or i just don't really know if i've ever
find a girl with so many of the green
flags that she had you know because we
talk about there's eight billion people
on a planet half of them are women it's
arrogant to think that there's nobody
that's going to be better than she is
okay so yeah just just like take that
thought out of your head right now beat
it with a stick until it's dead dig a
hole and bury a six feet under yeah
because okay because because that belief
doesn't serve you
okay
okay why would you subscribe to any
notion that doesn't serve what's best
for you
right no that's true that's true like
having an unhealthy attachment to a girl
that's not even in your life anymore and
thinking
is there going to be anyone better than
that
that belief does not serve you kill it i
guess it's done
i guess it just seems because you know i
don't mean to harp on modern women these
days but i feel like it seems so hard to
find many girls that have a lot of green
flags these days i know you did say
okay
well you did say i'm going to go through
all the
yeah you have to dig through a lot of
dirt to find gold right yeah right right
so i mean you know you're going to date
you're going to have some fun you're
going to deal with some crazies
some some nightmare might throw a log
through your front window you know one
day because you don't want to talk to
her anymore you're going to deal with
some [ __ ]
which is totally fine right it's part of
the process of digging
into the earth looking for gold right
you're gonna find some fool's gold you
know you're gonna get tripped a lot of
them are gonna have red flags you know
so don't even sweat it like
what is it that you're worried about
you're 31 like do you think your eggs
are drying up you're not going to have
kids or something like that like what
are you worried about no not that i'm
just i'm just
in hindsight looking back realizing that
she had so many green flags i just it's
the one itis that i got that i can't get
over and it's hard for me like better
because i don't have other options or a
better option so if you had more options
right now you'd be like you know she was
fun but
i mean we're you know they say that um
you know a business that you want to
work so hard that um
you know the people that hated you at
the beginning ask you if you're hiring
basically
so imagine that you get so good at being
you that game and making money you're
captivating you're not a boring guy you
know you take care of yourself
all that [ __ ] right
yeah and then
she sees you know this new version of
you with women around you because i mean
you know social media is good for that
you use it instagram i would imagine
yeah yeah yeah absolutely imagine you
know she now wants to move back to
california to be with you thinking how
stupid she was and at that point in time
you might even have a better girl and
you're gonna say you know what
lost your chance babe sorry
yeah yeah and the thing is too i feel
like i know that i was super blue peeled
when i was with her because you know she
would tell me things because she was
vegetarian she was like you know i'm
never going to cook a uh
meat
food with meat for you if we were to get
married and i'm like oh okay or you know
she liked recycling a lot so i started
recycling a lot and i was i was really
basically in her frame so you did all
this [ __ ] to please her basically yes
yeah yeah she left yeah
through a thousand
the book right concessions did i did i
just finished it was a great read i'm
going to leave a review too thank you
please yeah yes
yeah that's that's right i just
realization through i was you know
concession so and so in hindsight guys
you got to get used to saying no to
women
right like yeah
i remember my girl when i first met her
she was like mostly vegetarian
and like one of the first things i did
was i made steak
right
yeah
i didn't do that it was a bomb-ass steak
and she liked it she's like oh yeah yeah
it's more of this [ __ ] give me some more
of that right and i was just like oh
okay yeah sure yeah yeah whatever you
say yeah that's kind of how i was yeah
so
i mean
a woman's got to look up to you and she
can't possibly look up to you if you say
yes to every one of our demands okay
john needs to start recycling john i
need you to stop eating meat john i need
you to be more inclusive and i don't
know
a lot like that yeah whatever right yeah
no yeah like you know i'm on a grind
like i'm doing something like she wants
to see you doing stuff like what do you
do for a living
i work as a behavior therapist right now
um but i'm actually an aspiring
firefighter actually so okay well you
look more like a firefighter than a
behavioral therapist okay so you should
definitely do that firefighter
yes sir yes sir yes i'm going for it
balls to the wall
um i got all my credentials i'm just
applying now and hopefully getting hired
on soon but good good yeah you know
because i'm on my purpose like you said
chasing my purpose yeah that's that is
number one that is true
fighters like on the dating market
you tell like women when you're on a
dating app or senior prior or even have
a picture yourself there you know maybe
the calendar picture with the leggings
and all that sort of [ __ ] the overalls
yeah chick stick firefighters man milk
it milk it okay because that'll give you
an opportunity to get exposed to a lot
of uh women attractive women and there's
going to be a lot of dirt in there and
there's going to be some gold right so
you just spin the plates let the cream
rise to the top
wait for her to you know say hey john
you know where do we stand i dig your
vibe you know i want to you know like
you seen anybody else can we make this
exclusive wait for her to do all those
things like like follow exactly what i
laid out in the book i know it works
because i'm older than you and i've done
a lot of dumb [ __ ] that doesn't work and
i also also done the stuff that does
work and i've also talked to so many
guys now trust me follow that okay and i
also asked her out
so i'm telling you i was super blue
peeled and it's it's embarrassing to say
but now i've well i mean you definitely
want to ask a woman out you don't want
to let her ask you out or yeah yeah or i
mean ask her where we stand basically
like yeah you never have the word we
stand talk dude yeah like it always
comes from her first yeah all right
and then at that point and then you
decide for you because men are the
gatekeepers to relationships women are
the gatekeepers of sex women decide when
you're going to be intimate
guys decide whether or not they're going
to invite her into their lives and
introduce them to their family and if
they're going to be monogamous or if
they're not going to be monogamous like
you can decide exactly how it is you
want to structure your life because now
you're in a bargaining position
right when somebody comes at you and
says hey i want what you got
right like whenever i have a car for
sale like when i sold the r8 last last
fall put it up for sale 160 000 had some
dip shits that lowballed me i'll give
you 140 give me 100.
you know the one guy that that followed
my instructions i said no price is firm
cash same day
right because i'm in the bargaining
position i'm the one with the asset i'm
the guy that gets to set the rules so
make sure that you understand that you
have value as a guy and when she comes
at you with that where do we stand john
you're like okay cool that's awesome
now i get to decide whether or not i
want to invite her in my life and then
from then on in
now after that you just have to make
sure you don't [ __ ] out and go through
beta testation right no
yeah
my eyes have been open now so it's it's
it's enlightening it's in it's
enlightening all right man yeah i
appreciate everything rich thank you for
everything you do thanks hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you